Trascrizione: Maria Isabel Menendez-Leon
Revisore: ila S.
Allora, non c'è dubbio
che la storia personale...
vi dico subito, non vi faccio
arrivare alla fine come un thriller
sul perché le storie hanno così successo.
Io preferisco il tenente Colombo:
prima sappiamo l'assassino,
e poi scopriamo come si fa
a scoprire l'assassino.
Le storie sono così rilevanti
perché servono per sapere
perché io sono Maria Grazia
e non un'altra.
Cioè, perché ciascuno di noi
è quello che è,
perché è possibile riuscire
a vivere socialmente insieme,
e perché la nostra specie è la specie
che ha assunto la supremazia
nel processo evolutivo.
Quindi, le storie servono
per dire la mia identità,
per dire la mia società così com'è
e com'è fatta, e riconoscersi,
e perché noi riusciamo
a sopravvivere come specie.
Questo è l'assassino.
Adesso provo a raccontarvi,
molto brevemente
come si arriva all'assassino.
Non c'è ombra di dubbio,
che quando noi già da piccoli
abbiamo i genitori
che ci raccontano storie
ma appena riusciamo
a proferire qualche parola,
alle storie diciamo: "ancora".
E adoriamo da bambini le storie
che fanno un po' terrore e un po' paura.
In realtà, se ci pensiamo,
la cosa, l'immagine che ci viene in mente,
è quella di Sherazade
delle Mille e una Notte.
Lei, grazie alle storie,
si salva la pelle.
Se non fosse stata capace
di raccontare storie, sarebbe morta.
In realtà, vale anche per noi.
Cosa succede da bambini?
Cosa succede, il fatto che fino alla fine
della nostra vita raccontiamo storie?
Possiamo leggerle, possiamo vederle,
e oggi le troviamo in rete
o le sentiamo raccontare qui,
che sono state fino adesso storie.
Tutte molto interessanti,
e per noi, molto istruttive.
Io dovrei parlare di come le neuroscienze
raccontano questo successo.
Ci arrivo per gradi.
Vi racconto in primo luogo una storia,
una delle tante storie.
Quando la Francia si divide in due,
e il generale Pétain decide
di accettare di governare a Vichy,
in realtà, viene costruito
un piccolo libricino, questo qui,
e molti, noi diremmo oggi,
cartelloni pubblicitari,
che avevano scritto: "C'era una volta".
Dentro il libro che cosa viene raccontato?
Viene raccontato che ci sono
due bambini piccoli,
che vedono un adulto,
il nonno, che piange.
"Ma, perché piangi, nonno?".
E dice: "La Francia è sconfitta".
E i bambini dicono: "Chiamiamo una fata,
chiamiamo i maghi,
chiamiamo il mago Silvestro".
E lui diceva: "Quel mago è imprigionato.
Non è tempo di fate e di maghi".
Dice: "Ma io sacrifico,
dono la mia persona alla Francia
per aiutarla nelle sue disgrazie".
La storia, il raccontare storie,
è anche un modo per plasmare
la relazione con gli altri.
Questo è uno dei tanti esempi,
ma la storia è molto lunga.
Quest'immagine qui che non mandiamo
nel filmato è molto interessante
perché se voi andate in rete e la trovate,
scoprirete che chiunque la veda,
questi due triangoli e il cerchio
cominciano a entrare in relazione.
E quando si domanda:
"Ma che cos'è successo in quel filmato?"
Quasi tutti s'inventano
delle relazioni amorose e di conflitto
fra i due triangoli per ottenere
il successo con il cerchio.
In genere, sappiamo che simbolicamente
i due triangoli sono simboli maschili,
e il cerchio è un simbolo femminile.
Adesso comincio a provare a raccontarvi
qualche cosa sulle neuroscienze.
La forma più diffusa di storia
è il pettegolezzo.
Viviamo di pettegolezzi.
"Ma sai, Maria Grazia
è andata alla TED conference".
Se lo dico così, c'è già tutto
un implicito che è una storia.
E alla domanda che veniva presentata
dallo speaker precedente: "Perché?"
"Perché è andata alla TED conference?"
devo cominciare a raccontare una storia.
Il perché è una storia.
Lo spiegarsi il perché delle cose,
la sola risposta, è già una storia.
Ma la cosa interessante
è che si è scoperto,
in termini di neuroscienze,
che non c'è nessuna differenza
nelle relazioni sociali,
addirittura, si pensa
che sia la stessa origine,
dal "grooming" degli animali.
Lo spulciarsi.
Noi in inglese sappiamo benissimo
che "groom" è lo sposo.
Sappiamo anche che vuol dire
che comunque io cerco di adescarti,
nella terminologia,
il "grooming" nei primati,
non solo quelli, anche nei gorilla,
serve a definire le gerarchie.
Quindi, il "grooming",
il pettegolezzo, è una gerarchia.
Io col pettegolezzo posso accreditare
o togliere la reputazione ad una persona.
Quindi, è una validazione
e una modalità di gerarchia.
E noi siamo non solo ascoltatori,
ma siamo anche produttori di storie.
Perché sembrerebbe che siamo
produttori di storia?
Perché la storia ci toglie
dal momento del presente,
dal qui e ora.
La storia, il presente,
lo posso solo raccontare dopo,
e quindi mi toglie dallo spazio
e mi toglie dal tempo.
E dà senso: la frammentazione
di tanti presenti
costruisce il senso di quello
che faccio e di quello che sono.
E questo senso mette insieme,
sembra costruire,
il fluire della dinamica del tempo.
Il primo soggetto che racconta
la storia è il nostro corpo,
perché il nostro corpo dice
come ha interagito nel tempo coll'ambiente
e ha interagito nel tempo
coll'ambiente all'esterno
e con il nostro ambiente interno.
Se noi siamo persone che sono cresciute
in una storia emotiva,
fortemente rigida,
magari fortemente astiosa,
non c'è ombra di dubbio,
che i tratti somatici del nostro volto
e delle nostre dinamiche espressive
lo raccontano.
E quindi, il primo testo
che racconta la storia di chi siamo,
ancora prima di aprire la bocca,
è il nostro corpo.
Ma siamo in realtà, con le storie,
non solo fuori dal nostro tempo
e fuori dal nostro spazio.
Siamo anche alla ricerca della possibilità
di vivere altre vite, non solo la mia.
Nel momento in cui sento un'altra vita,
immediatamente la confronto con la mia.
La natura, il processo biologico,
ha prodotto negli esseri umani
una cosa che ormai moltissimi conoscono,
è una ricerca tutta italiana,
fatta all'università di Parma,
di cui poi negli Stati Uniti, in Giappone
si sono fatte tante ricerche analoghe,
che è la parolina magica,
che oggi è molto utilizzata,
ma bisogna stare anche
tanto attenti a utilizzarla,
che è la modalità empatica.
Il sistema "mirror",
scoperto all'università di Parma,
ci consente di capire che cosa succede
dentro il nostro cervello
e dentro il nostro corpo
quando sentiamo una storia.
Se una persona ci racconta una storia,
noi è come se riproducessimo
nel nostro corpo,
comprendendo il linguaggio
e vendendo i movimenti,
esattamente che cosa ha fatto
un'altra persona.
Per cui, le storie ci fanno davvero,
non solo idealmente,
concretamente, vivere
oltre alla nostra vita,
la vita degli altri.
E la vita degli altri entra,
tramite il sistema neurale,
nella nostra stessa vita.
Per cui, noi siamo noi,
perché siamo anche
tutto l'insieme delle relazioni
che abbiamo avuto con altri.
E l'elemento centrale,
lo vedremo nella slide successiva,
di questa dinamica,
è la dimensione emotiva.
Le storie sono affascinanti.
Pensate al modello del fascino
di un sentimento come l'amore,
dove il modello per noi occidentali
è Giulietta e Romeo.
E se pensiamo alla nostra cultura,
il modello dell'inganno
è Cappuccetto Rosso.
Per cui l'apprendimento
è un apprendimento
del tentativo di capire
come imparare
a comportarci socialmente
di fronte ad alcune cose
che dobbiamo affrontare.
Questo ormai spiega molto bene
perché i bambini chiedono,
non una, ma cento volte,
di vedere lo stesso cartone,
e cento volte la stessa identica storia.
Perché abbiamo bisogno
d'imparare tutti i particolari,
perché così in quella situazione,
impariamo quali sono i rischi,
le difese, i premi e le sanzioni.
C'è un esperimento,
uno dei tanti sperimenti...
notate che sulla narrazione
oggi si sta investendo molto
in termini di ricerca di neuroscienze.
Moltissime quantità di soldi
sono investite in quella direzione
proprio per il loro fascino,
per la loro presa
e per il ruolo educativo,
sociale e dell'identità.
C'è un interessante esperimento,
oltretutto fatto da un neuro-economista,
il quale ha provato a mettere
di fronte allo schermo
una storia drammatica.
E si è scoperto che, nel momento in cui
aumentava il grado di drammatizzazione,
nel corpo di tutti coloro
che partecipavano all'esperimento,
avvenivano due impennate
di due particolari tipi di ormoni.
Il primo è l'ossitocina,
quello che ci serve per metterci
nei panni degli altri.
La modalità che ci consente
d'incominciare a pensare
che io mi metto dal suo lato,
dal suo punto di vista.
L'altro, in realtà, è stato il cortisolo,
che è l'ormone dello stress, dell'ansia,
ma anche del grado di attenzione.
Per cui, man mano
che la condizione emotiva sale,
il nostro grado di attenzione cresce.
Quest'insieme di elementi,
legati alla possibilità
di rispecchiarsi negli altri,
alla possibilità di essere un soggetto
che è fatto della sua storia,
che è fatta di tutte le storie,
di tutti i pettegolezzi che ha sentito
nell'arco della sua vita,
produce il fatto
che noi possiamo immaginare,
e immaginiamo per simboli.
Penso al primo speaker di oggi,
che ha disegnato: era una storia,
ed era una storia fatta di simboli.
Ecco, sembrerebbe che questa capacità,
legata alla narrazione,
è quello che ha fatto sì
che l'homo sapiens sapiens
predominasse rispetto
ad altri tipi di ominidi,
con i quali, comunque, ha convissuto,
e che ci consente oggi di dire che siamo
dei soggetti produttori di cultura.
Ma credo, penso, ritengo,
che il successo della storia
nasca dal fatto
che nessuna storia è esterna,
che nessuna storia
che raccontiamo a noi stessi
sia in grado di spiegare con le parole,
la complessità vera dei nostri vissuti.
E quindi, c'è spazio
per tantissime altre storie.
Tutte una diversa dall'altra.
Tanto quanto siamo diversi
ciascuno di noi uno dall'altro.
(Applausi)